hey what's up guys my name is the cherno
and welcome to another episode of
network chat programs episode 27 no it's
not it's actually an episode 28 always
got me there guys phalaris but it is
episode 20 out of network a programming
and today we're going to take a look at
basically just giving the console if
your commands that we can enter so that
we can we can retrieve information about
clients and everything's going on okay
now important we're just going to go
this is going to be like I've kind of
like a freestyle kind of improvised
asian thing I've actually got any code
prepared or anything so we're just going
to see whatever pops into my head we're
going to implement basically on the spot
there's almost a live stream but some
we're just going to go into the server
main he okay so we're gonna close
everything that we don't need so login
can go away client can go away client
window you know server will stay so the
client can go away server main and
server other than really two things we
need we should probably also just open
the login here just because login will
be used it this is actually where our
main method is for our client okay so we
should keep that open so that we can
actually launch our client now that
being said seven main this service over
current work sorry we have some command
line arguments here which which
essentially let us set a port here that
we want to bind the server to again then
we set the server so obviously it goes
into new server main and we start the
server ossible yeah goes into here and
then you can see that we get a new
server here now what we want to do is we
want to kind of I guess give ourselves a
few commands that we can type in so that
we can essentially well we can run we
can run certain I guess changes to the
server okay so one thing we definitely
want to do is is just I think like the
number one thing they probably pops into
you guys heads is you know how many
clients are online and who are they okay
so you know if your servers been running
you've been there for a while apart from
getting all the chat logs and
everything's gone great you might also
want to just see who's online right now
okay as the server so you want to print
it to the console of course because the
server has no GUI it's gone Oakland the
server doesn't have a graphical user
interface like client dollars doesn't
have an application it's just like a
terminal application it is a console
based application now in order to do
this I like to run this in the managed
clients okay well not not necessarily I
mean this run thing right we have a few
threads let's talk about this first of
all we have a few threads okay we've got
we've got this
managed thread if we go up here you can
see where the run manage then receive
there's so many threads here now the run
threat of course is what runs the server
initially that runs manage clients and
receive now inside this run thing I'm
just going to go ahead and say well true
again remember this is on the run thread
we can accept certain things and I
shouldn't say well true i should say
while running we can accept certain
commands so in other words while we're
running ah well okay you know what yeah
okay let's do this way so while we're
running list let's go ahead and let the
user enter certain commands again it's
the way that we can do that is just
using a scanner pretty much so scanner
we should do this outside of the that's
outside of the for loops of scanner
scanner equals new scanner here and then
for the parameter will just put system
got in okay and put that we want the
java.util.scanner here to finish all
right and this this just allows us to
scan certain characters okay whether
that be from a file whether that be in
this point in this case from the from
the console input okay so if we type
something in the console the the scanner
I'll be able to pick it up so the way we
can do that is so string you know I
guess maybe text equals scan up and dot
some and then put a little things here
okay so the thing that you want to do is
get the let's get next line okay not
next not you know you might have heard
of something like well there's a lot of
things you could do there's like next
int for example that's used if you want
to get the next integer but next line
will retrieve the entire line that the
user is typed and because of course we
kind of do what the entire line right
because um because after after the
command the user presses enter anyway
right after we've given the server
command we press ENTER serve advances it
to the next line so then therefore we
want the entire line so this will return
the entire line now you might be like
hang on this is in a while loop won't
just keep doing it just infinitely and
no because similarly how we have this
receive thing going where I go where we
basically run socket receiving it and
then just kind of hangs there it just
listens there without stopping well
that's kind of that's kind of the same
deal that we want to do with the other
or with scanner right that's how it
works it just
it waits there patiently until it's
given input that's why we have to have
it in and separate threat and we do
right make sure that managed clients is
in its own thread you can see it is and
make sure that also receive is in its
own thread and it is okay otherwise of
course if it's not they both have while
running loops so in other words it will
never get down to the scanner line of
code that we want to we want it to be at
okay so that's how that works make sure
it's on a separate thread otherwise your
entire server will just freeze until you
type something in there essentially and
you don't want that happen obviously so
it's going to the next line okay that's
our text right and now we can do things
based on what the text is so if text
does not for example that's a harder way
of doing it but if if text dot starts
with for example a slash so let's just
make /b console commands right we could
do a hyphen we could do whatever you
want let's just go with / okay so if it
doesn't start with / that it's just
going to be a message so we can go ahead
and go send to all and then the string
message will just be I think we have to
we would have to yeah so let's do em and
then so M plus text and then we'll also
do something long lines I think I think
the way that this works is we put the do
we put the name of this service store do
we go like this maybe like that I get um
plus an end character yeah I've actually
forgotten how this all works but this
should work in fact let's just test this
out right now oops else Oh in fact we
could probably just continue just to
reduce the stuff but ok let's just test
out if this works right just so we can
kind of procedurally test this test this
stuff out so i'll launch the server here
else i'll go to log in and i'll launch
that will type in a yarn over here
whoops localhost 8192 login awesome
we've successfully connected let's say
something to the to the server hey we
should get the server to print out
anything in receives by the way that's
kind of important but let's see if we
can say something so hey cherno yeah and
then you can see that on the client we
get from sir
hey Cho know so you can see it works and
I'm kind of having a conversation but on
the server okay now important thing is
we probably do want to print out
whatever packet we we actually receive
so I'm over here in our in receive when
we do the center all and where that is
where the center all ok here it is so
whoops sent to all and sent to all when
we're about to send it we should
probably just print it out as well okay
so the way that we're going to print it
out is really similar to how we do in
the client okay we want to kind of strip
it of everything we can in fact I
probably is going to copy the code from
the client so we don't have to type it
out but in the client window under
receive we've got the the msoft so we go
a message substring and then we split it
and then we console it okay let's close
copy that code bring it back into server
here and then um uh yeah message the
substring as you can see is there and
then let's just print it out okay so if
we um okay so that prints out everything
so if message dot starts oh here we go
this is another thing we can add okay
this is awesome so first of all if
message starts with an n then we can do
the following oops where is this here
okay oops i forgot the court so we're
going to do that if the métis off of
them so that i'll stop this you guys
probably can't see that very well but it
was just printing out server because of
course that's the client trying to
connect with the server there okay cool
now I'm what we what we do want to do
though is let's just quickly say
something like hey and there you go so i
said ! and we got that right there which
is awesome all right anyway let's just
cut this out for now let's close both of
them alright so that works now what we
might also want to do right we haven't
really done much right so far just so
you get just for a little recap it's
been going on for a while holy shared
nine minutes that really fly past that
quickly anyway sorry guys
um I seem to be taking my time here this
is a bit of a you know the series is
kind of officially ended so I'm just
come taking a busy but um so we've now
now the only thing we've got it on here
is just let the server communicate with
the client as long as it doesn't start
with a slash if it does subway / those
bit of a command ok so if text starts
with ah no not starts with if texts are
we could go if text okay let's just go
if text dot equals / raw okay are in
fact we could just go text dodd
substring and then just go one and that
will just trim it a bit so that'll get
rid of that / so then we can just save
tax equals raw let's go ahead and enable
raw mode and i'll tell you what raw mode
is in a minute if our most actually raw
let's just go raw ah equals not raw
again i'll explain what that does in a
minute but we always go ahead and go
private boolean raw equals false okay
now raw mode something I've just made up
is um is essentially a we get to see the
actual packets of anything that gets
printed okay so you can see here in
center all for example we've got if
message that starts with M it then only
print that okay otherwise what we could
do is we could say if raw so for all
mode is on let's just print out the
entire message again including all of
the prefixes post fixes everything okay
and what this will do is any kind of
stuff that we send to every client it
will catch okay that's one way of doing
it right that's one way of doing it we
could do it right here I'm not really
not going to do it here because then
obviously this is only messages to get
sent it's not about connection back its
we won't want to seek in action packets
and stuff like that so in other words in
process wherever we get something you
can see the string here we can just say
if raw so if wrong road is on let's just
print it okay so system dot out dot
print line or Cicero and then draw enter
our string
alright and that's only for all murders
on ok string I can't spell string okay
now um that's cool and that that will
work that's only the stuff that we
receive not the weeds and so you could
go ahead and say it'll probably make it
a bit too complicated if I if I put raw
we could set a level of raw as well I'm
gonna leave that up to you guys because
you could really do anything with this
and I don't want to kind of spend ages
doing that but I'm essentially raw mode
in this case we'll just let us see
whatever diet whatever packets are
coming in okay and they'll print it out
ben de mattah strings okay awesome now
let's go ahead and explain this real
quick so this this essentially sets r or
equal to not raw okay so in other words
if roar is if roar is true this will
give us false this week or false right
if Rahl is true that'll give us false if
we're always false that'll give us true
guess what just it just toggles it it
flips it whenever we type in raw so
let's take a look at what they can look
like yeah i'm going to start the server
here it's actually got a bit client but
i'll go back to seven men are more then
start that alright so wait so will login
again turn our local host and one on to
log in and let's turn raw mode on okay
solve them to untie to enroll now which
probably give some kind of feedback like
server enabled but you can see right
over here that oh whoops so let's go /
raw that's see that's a probability and
you can see now we can see what packets
were actually receiving if I do turn if
I go / or again it will turn it off and
you'll see you can see that we know let
me get that stuff now let's to unroll
mode on and then try and connect here so
we'll cut right connectors yarn now and
we the hell happen that we got a bit of
a address already in use are we sorry we
tried to start another server not what
we wanted to do obviously couldn't start
another cervical authority we try to
start with try to start it on port 8192
which is already in use as you can see
by this service i told us that we can't
stop it okay my bad so y on localhost at
192 log in and you can see over here or
we get
is a connection packet we can say here
yawn and we get an identifier all that
identify would get any way but here it
is /c flashy on now let's try and this
is probably going to be hard for you
guys to see soon so I might just grab
the console and pop it up here all right
now let's go ahead and for example let's
just try and close this okay so this is
I think this is hi I think this is yeah
okay let's try and close that and you
can see what we get here is a
disconnection pack up let's go in
Terminator server and the client alright
where is it here it is so you can see
the before I said client disconnecting
it got addie packet you could see it
starts with adi a /d ok and that was a
disconnection back end so raw merge is
really lets us see kind of what's going
on ok which i think is awesome okay
that's that's raw mode explain pretty
much one other thing i want to add of
course is being able to see clients who
are online and that's pretty simple as
well so we'll go to else if whoops so
else if we could do a switch statement
for this as well text equals ah i donno
what will be a good name for command you
can see everyone who's online maybe
clients I don't know can't think right
now so if if this is the case and let's
print out a list of clients so for in i
equals 0 is less than clients sighs i
plus plus we can system to allow to
print line ah the everything about the
client so let's just get the clock the
current client so server client c equals
clients clients get I so we'll looping
through it and we're getting it at the
current index so C dot name maybe first
plus our i will put in brackets the
identifier so plus C dot get ID plus
will close the bracket of course and
then we'll make it maybe like a colon
not another sad face sad face but um
we'll make a colon and then
go ahead and leave a space there and
maybe put in the address so the address
plus two string to string plus because
it's a known address so we don't want
the actual memory location or anything
or the hash of the class arm plus so we
got the address and then we'll get the
port and I think that's about it we
don't need to have a temps or anything
yeah so that'll print out everything and
just to make it look nice we might just
before the array we might just print out
something like clients followed by maybe
another system dot out dot print line
that just has a bunch of equals just so
it's like a nice-looking arm kind of fun
an underscore kind of thing you'll see
what it looks like anyway that's it
again then at the end we might do
something similar okay just so we can
see it okay so let's just test this out
right now i'm going to start the server
so serve a man i'm going to start on
live in this login thing a Turner local
host localhost a 192 login alright sweet
so we've logged in here let's go ahead
and type in client a slash clients and
yeah you can see here it says clients
and then we got sure no we can see our
identification number we can see where
we can actually from and what port we're
using okay great let's launch another
client now and see if it prints both of
them hey one and two login ok now let's
type in clients again oops / clients
false lash lines and there you are okay
so we got Jonah we got yarn they both
got separate ideas you can say that
obviously condition from the same spot
you can see that they do have different
sockets as well different ports rather
and there you go so there's two
different clients as you can see a
connection to the server right now okay
sweet now that's pretty much going to
wrap up this tutorial okay hopefully I
gave you guys enough information so that
you can add whatever you want into it I
am gonna probably next episode we're
going to talk about kicking people off
some of the words if if someone I guess
if you're the server administrator you
want to ban someone not ban someone but
kick someone off you could we could talk
about banning that would be rather easy
we could talk about IP banning for
example or name banning as well let me
know if you guys want that it's really
up to you guys honestly it's up to you
guys at this point could we finish the
series so but what we will do is kicking
people off in the next episodes in other
words i guess kicking people from the
client from the server and the other
thing we'll cover in the following
episode after the next one is probably
going to be the the list of people
online in the GUI i guess and right now
we can retrieve a list of people online
as a server in our consoles you can see
here but next episode or rather the
upside off so this is episode 28 then
episode 30 probably will talk about
displaying an actual list that you can
bring up in your GUI you can see who's
online anyway that's going to wrap up
this episode of network share
programming hope you guys did enjoy
please hit like button again comment let
me know what you guys want to see the
next one and the next one after the next
one after that and I've already told you
guys what's going happen probably for
the next two episodes but episodes after
that let me know alright comment below
bye